For our experts and emotion interview.
We will be speaking with
Doctor Nancy Isenberg on
emotion regulation in children.
Dr Eisenberg is a regents professor of
psychology at Arizona State University.
Her research interests
pertained to social,
emotional and moral development and
her books include the caring child,
the roots of pro social behavior in
children and how children develop.
Dr Eisenberg has been editor
of psychological bulletin
and child development
perspectives and has received career
contribution awards from the American
psychological association,
the association for Psychological
Science and the International Society for
research on behavioral development.
I now turn to our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Nancy Isenberg on
emotion regulation in children.
So welcome Nancy.
Thank you for speaking with us today.
Thank you Jen.
What I thought might be a nice way to
start off our conversation is to ask you a
little bit about what first
got you interested in emotion.
Um,
well,
I was still studying
mall development and um,
back when I started there wasn't
really a field of emotion. Um,
I was studying a moral
reasoning and empathy and um,
assessing empathy back then.
People did it with, uh, people's,
particularly children's
self reports to stories.
And make a long story short,
we found that wasn't working
very well with children.
And so we just started to,
um,
try to use a nonverbal measures
like physiological measures.
So I had to start reading
the physiological literature
because I was trying to
get it empathic arousal, um, and uh,
you skin conductance,
heart rate to get it arouse on children.
And that takes you into
the emotion literature.
Also to our work,
we found that there were some kids who,
uh,
were more empathic and they were also
seem to be more socially competent in
general while the kids who wha,
um,
bless socially competent,
we're more prone to what
we call personal distress,
which is the tendency to experience,
um,
averse of emotions when fund it with
someone else's negative emotion.
And so I started thinking
about why this might be,
and it led me into thinking about the
ability to regulate emotion successful and
how that may play out and
children's social behavior.
And so I had to start thinking
about individual differences
and emotionality and
also the ability to
modulite that emotionality.
So it's really coming from the empathy
literature that led me at first a
unbenounced to myself really
into the emotion literature.
So I wanted to then ask you
a few questions about your
research that's been just
so influential in this domain. So
I mean, you're widely known for,
you know,
your pioneering work in
a study of developmental
processes that have been vital
for healthy social and emotional
responding and children.
And I wonder from your perspective,
what you see as some of the most critical
discoveries in your work on emotion
regulation and children.
Um,
uh,
so I'm not going to
have to do with empathy,
but I think we're going to talk about
that a little bit. Uh, so wait on that.
Um,
uh,
we tried to differentiate between emotion
related regulatory processes that were
more applicable. Um, coming out
of the temperament literature,
there's a discussion of these kinds of
FFO control processes and also processes
that affect behavior.
But seeing the be a little less voluntary,
how do to regulate what
we call reactive control,
like the child who's impulsive
and always approaching,
but has trouble inhibiting that word
child who seems to be very regulated,
maybe because they don't,
the sitting still,
they're not getting into trouble,
but the actually overly inhibited
and having difficulty approaching new
situations,
dealing with new people.
So I'm what people call
behavioral inhibition.
So we've been interested
in these more processes.
The kid can easily manage,
like make themselves where you're like,
stop a behavior and make
themselves activated behavior
even when they don't want
to voluntarily shift and focus attention
when they have to versus these other
kinds of behaviors like impulsivity
and behavioral inhibition where they,
the child seems to have less control,
but it does effect in a sense regulate
their behavior and outcomes for them.
And we showed that actually more recently
about statistically we can really
differentiate these
two kinds of processes,
but also they provide unique prediction
of psychopathology and a symptoms,
uh, you know, externalizing problems,
particularly to some degree internalizing
problems like social withdrawal and
anxiety, uh, but also
social competence. Um,
uh, and uh, empathy
and prosocial behavior,
other kinds of aspects
of social competence.
So that's one important thing.
Um,
actually when we started doing
the work in the early nineties,
there wasn't really much good
research will be a little,
but there wasn't much good research.
They used measures that assessed something
really close to regulation rather
than a general kind of doing
good at everything. Um,
so the early measures off and threw
together emotionality and regulation or
regulation and social competence.
And so we tried to sort out and get
clean or measures and we had longitudinal
data and the nine days
and then thereafter.
So we were one of the early people
to document how important these early
individual differences in regulatory,
these voluntary voluntary regulatory
processes work for predicting outcomes for
kids later. Um, for instance,
in our first study we had teachers and
parents just reporting on kids' ability
to focus and shift attention.
And we found that it not only related
to kids ability to manage anger at that
age, their popularity, the
social competence more broadly,
but it predicted two,
four and six years later into the school
setting problem behaviors at home.
So we were surprised how powerful
predictor just these ratings were from
teachers and preschool and that really
got us interested in following, um,
the kids and longer and looking at
emotional regulation and more detail.
But, um, yeah, so mapping out
some of those pathways, uh,
which a lot of people are doing now,
but people weren't doing it as much then.
I was wondering if you could say a
little bit more about what you see as
particularly important about the role
of adaptive and flexible autonomic
responding when it comes to
healthy emotion regulation
processes and children as
well. Uh, by, I dunno, I'm like,
are you talking physiological?
Yeah, exactly. Oh, um,
well I guess, uh, um,
I was thinking of more automatic, but, um,
well I think,
hmm.
So be more like vago town,
um,
kids who can manage a,
the Bagel system,
which is seen,
it's to do with heart
rate and respiration.
And it's seen as a system
that affects kids. Um,
physiological emotion regulation and uh,
kids who have what we call high
day or tone seem to be able to,
um,
they were more flexible system.
They can suppress the system so that they,
uh,
arousal rises when need be in situations.
Um,
and it seems to affect the
maybe be related to their
ability to focus attention.
And so it's important that kids be able
to change the attention and the arousal
with the context. Um, for instance,
focus in on something
strong like shut out other,
uh, aspects of the environment
when they need to. Um,
I'm not,
I don't think we really know very well
how that relates to though Ffo camp.
It does correlate in some studies with
these effortful control processes I've
been talking about,
but not that well.
And so I don't think we know enough
about how like the voluntary attention
process processes and the ability to
activate and regulate behaviors needed,
we light to those autonomic systems
because the literature is not that
consistent.
It's an important direction for future
years to really parse apart those nuances.
Yes. And it, I think it depends
on context. I'm a student of mine,
just a did a master's
that's being published,
assume that he found,
for instance,
Vagal tone was correlated with measures
of FFO control behavioral measures of
self regulation in a laboratories,
a situation only for kids who were shy
because for those kids that seem to be,
they really had to bring me after four
control to bear and that situation,
um,
to do well.
And so for them the relationship was
stronger than for kids that weren't shy.
In this laboratory situation it might
be very different and a non laboratory.
Sure.
So
that's really interesting
work you're doing. Um,
it makes me want to ask you also about
another line of work that I think you
alluded to earlier,
which is the critical work that you've
conducted on the study of children's
capacity for empathy or the ability to
try to really understand the emotions of
others in their environment.
And I wondered if you could describe what
you see as the critical role of these
empathy related behaviors and adaptive
social behavior and adjustment.
Um,
well one thing we tried to do and building
on the work of Dan bats and he's a
social psychologist was differentiate
different empathy related responses.
Um,
people used to use the word empathy
to refer to just about any emotional
response to somebody else's emotion
that wasn't totally off the wall and
somewhat related to what the
other person's feeling. Um,
we differentiated empathy,
which we call,
we really make define that is feeling
a highly similar emotion as the other
person.
And we differentiated that from sympathy,
which is concern for the other person.
So I can feel sadness when you sad,
which would be empathy.
But then if I feel concerned for you,
that would be sympathy.
And then Dan Batson talked
about personal distress,
which is when the emotions
become so aversive that I'm folk,
I like say you're sad and it makes me
anxious and depressed or depressed or
stressed and those emotions of us of,
and I focus on myself.
So it's two arousing.
I mean we can all think of times where
somebody is telling us something that bad
that happened to them and we can hardly
bear listening because it's making us
anxious.
That would be personal distress.
And that differentiation is very
important because they relate to different
behaviors.
Um,
it's the sympathy particularly
and maybe sometimes empathy,
but we think empathy often
leads to sympathy. Um,
that relates to helping others
to being more socially competent,
being sensitive and personal distress
actually is associated with trying to
avoid the other person that is
evoking the emotion and us and also,
um, is not related to a
better social competence.
Um, uh, I'm getting a cup of coffee.
That's fine. I wonder if I
could ask you about, I mean,
this is just really fascinating and I
wanted to ask you about just a third area
of are with your work that looks
at the relationship between, uh,
parental emotional express 70 and the
development of children's regulatory
abilities and broader kind of
social emotional functioning.
And I wondered if you could speak to
what you see as the most central findings
on this inner relationship between a
parent and the emotional wellbeing and
regulatory capacity of the child.
Can I say one more thing about the last
one thing I didn't mention is the lack
of empathy and uh, you know, most
kids do experience some empathy,
but there's some kids that
don't experience much and
that's the really scary a
situation.
I think.
I'm not experiencing empathy for others.
It seems to be part of psychopathic kinds
of tendencies where kids can be cruel
and manipulative and so forth.
So empathy sensitizes us and maybe often
may inhibit aggression if we started
feeling the other's distress when we start
to do something bad to them, hit them,
whatever. We're less likely to
do those kinds of behaviors.
So I think empathy can be an
inhibitor of problematic behavior.
Interesting. Um, so on
the parenting issue,
Oh gosh,
there's so much one could
talk about depending on what
outcome you're interested
in. But if I had to pick, you know,
a few most important things,
uh,
and kind of focus more
in on the emotion side,
but other than say aggression
or other kinds of issues. Um,
suddenly parents being supportive,
uh,
being supportive of the child's emotions,
trying to talk about emotions,
at least in this culture,
I should say that some of these parenting
behaviors may not be at work the same
way in other cultures. Um, uh,
being sensitive to the child
wants and needs and feelings,
expressing, um, uh,
positive emotion with the child when
dealing with the child when appropriate.
Of course, uh, uh,
not overly expressing hostile,
negative emotions and the
home and interactions with
the child course said you
have to at sometimes and
it's part of everyday life.
But if the home atmosphere is more these
hostile kinds of emotions and warm,
supportive emotions,
kids that's associated with a lot
of negative outcomes for children.
Um,
and we guide to kind of
learning to manage emotions and,
uh, being well-regulated
in regard to emotions.
Probably also the, the issue of, um,
discussing coaching children,
discussing emotions,
not avoiding,
talking about dealing with
emotions in a natural way,
in everyday situations. Uh, you know,
parents can ask the child
why they feel a certain way.
Talk to them about how that's natural.
What can one do about it?
Uh, how can you feel? What can you
do to make yourself feel better?
These kinds of behaviors seem to be
very useful in helping kids learn to
regulate their emotions. And in
fact, in John Gottman's work, uh,
going back has also been
related to the Spago, uh,
tone ability. Um, people call
it our say, by the way, but,
um, it's, uh, the mother,
the parents who were high and met her
emotion, able to accept the emotion,
talk about emotion, deal with that,
had kids that had better vagal tone.
Um, so it's all interconnected there. Uh,
so would be important.
But you know, parenting,
there's lots of aspects that are
important and including reasonable wool
setting, high expectations,
not accessibly high,
that it's impossible, but
depending on the outcome, um,
the parent wants also modeling,
I mean modeling empathy,
I mean who knows what
genetics comes in here.
But parents that are more sympathetic
have kids that are more sympathetic,
you know,
parents that are more prosocial of kids
that are more prosocial part of there
may be genetically transmitted but
prob probably part of its modeling.
What implications do you think these
signings might have for trying to develop,
you know, emotion focused
interventions for children? You know,
um, well people are already doing, um,
sometimes without calling that the paths
curriculum of Mike Greenberg friends
sense is designed to deal
with problem behaviors. Uh,
primarily.
But what they do is teach kids about their
own and other's emotions had identify
them, uh, what they are, how to, um,
differentiate emotions. What
do you do about emotions? Uh,
um, what are strategies one can use
when you're angry? For instance,
of another child?
Uh,
they teach themselves
regulatory techniques like, um,
they have a picture of a stoplight
on a wall and you know, talk about,
look at the light, stop, think before
you do something when you're upset.
So I actually,
a number of the interventions out
there involve teaching about emotion,
emotion regulation and
they do have some effects,
particularly for the kids that
have the most problems. Um,
there's not so many with parenting and
it seems to me that that's an area that
is really ripe for more
research helping there.
I Susan Landry,
he's done some work that teachers,
parents kind of best
practices of socialization,
the kind of thing I was just talking
about, being supportive, uh, sensitive,
using appropriate discipline and kids
have a number of good outcomes that seem
to,
if you seem to reflect
a better regulation.
Um,
but there's very little work where
parents are taught how to coach children
about emotions,
teach them strategies,
how to talk effectively about emotions,
um,
these kinds of strategies.
So I think that's an area that
could be developed a lot more.
So as you think about where the future
of this field is headed and in what areas
could be developed more, what would
you say as you look forward, where,
where are the most important discovery
is going to be going to be and you're in
your eyes?
Well,
in the prevention areas we were just
talking about this a lot to be done. Um,
I think one could use a lot of this
information more than we currently are,
particularly outside.
We're doing a better job in the
schools then outside of the schools.
But you know,
if the schools are teaching children
about emotions and emotion regulation,
but they have a terrible environment
at home, it probably helps some,
but we could do a lot more,
probably we could get the
parents to compliment the
school intervention and some
people are trying to do that.
But to a very limited degree, um,
obviously the work in the
biological areas is important than,
uh,
no psych and so forth where they're
trying to map some of the circuits to do
with emotion, emotion regulation.
How do these all connect?
Um, how do we make decisions then, um,
this is going to be very important and,
and I think it's going to
dominate the field actually.
I'm thinking it's extremely important,
but I also think it's really important.
We don't lose sight of
behavior and the environment,
um, those inputs, uh, genetics
is getting very important.
People looking at a genetic
differences related to emotion,
emotion regulation.
But we will need to look at how
these interact with the environment,
the home environment,
the school environment too,
because that seems to affect
how the genes play out,
the genetic tendencies. Um, and, uh,
I think this work is really
the wave of the future,
but I'm a little concerned
that the environment and,
um,
other aspects are going to get lost
in the rush to find totally mostly
biological solutions and,
uh, answers to the questions.
So then what advice do you have for
future students who are thinking about
embarking in this area? What
might you tell them? Um,
get his multi-method as you can.
Uh,
it's important to learn a whole of ray.
I mean,
I think learning some
about biological measures,
learning about behavioral measures.
Um, uh, learning, you know,
facial expressions.
There's all kinds of ways to get at these,
the phenomenon related to emotion,
emotion regulation and their outcomes.
Um,
so the bladder,
the toolbox you have in terms of methods,
the better,
um, also, uh,
to not just stick to one literature
if had developmentalist we the adult
literature of your social psychologist,
the developmental literature is
critical lead the clinic. You know,
clinicians are doing a lot of
work, obviously relevant, uh,
the biological areas.
I mean,
now we have to be reading papers and
a lot of the biological journals.
Um, you really need to get
cross areas in psychology,
but also even in the other disciplines
much more than in the past.
Well, thank you so much for speaking
with us today. Nancy was my pleasure.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Nancy Isenberg
from Arizona State University.
Thank you so much again.